[Musique]
je suis une femme je suis une personne
plutôt douce empathique serviable à
l'écouté de mes émotions et de celle des
autres
quand je suis triste je n'ai pas envie
de pleurer
et quand j'ai peur je n'ai pas honte de
le dire
en fait mon caractère est proche de
celui de beaucoup d'autres femmes et
vous dit peut-être que je suis née comme
ça que nous sommes nous les femmes
biologiquement prédestiné à être douce
sensible en batik et serviable ça c'est
mois à 3 ans quand j'ai su que j'allais
devoir aller à l'école primaire je
n'avais pas du tout envie
j'étais terrifiée je vais bien
l'environnement ma maison mon papa ma
maman je voulais pas aller dans un
endroit inconnu avec des gens inconnus
alors quand je rentre à l'école et ben
j'arrêtais pas de pleurer j'étais
complètement perdu et les dames qui
s'occupait de moi à l'école
eh ben elle me prenait dans leurs bras
et elle me consoler jusqu'à ce que ça
passe mais je n'étais pas la seule à
pleurer les petit garçon qui était avec
moi à l'école ils pleuraient aussi
autant que moi ils étaient perdus comme
moi sauf que les dames elles et prenait
pas dans leurs bras alors disait est un
petit garçon ça pleure pas prend tout en
main
reprends toi sois courageux
quand j'ai quitté la primaire moi
j'avais pas beaucoup changé avec mes
copines on parlait toujours beaucoup nos
émotions de nos joies de nos peines
et quand on était triste on pleurait
encore mais les garçons qui est avec nos
collèges il pleurait déjà plus alors je
vais pas dire qu'il parlait pas il
parlait beaucoup plus que nous mêmes
mais il parlait d' actions d' aventure
de ce qu'ils avaient fait de ce qu'ils
allaient faire mais il parlait pas de
leurs émotions
en réalité tout ça n'a rien d'un dîner
on ne fait qu'appliquer ce qu'on nous a
appris depuis tout petits à savoir qu'il
existe deux catégories les hommes et les
femmes et que notre sexe de naissance
détermine celle à laquelle on appartient
et avec ces catégories viennent des
comportements recommandé ainsi les
filles on va nous encourager à être
douce sensible empathique et les garçons
on va les encourager à être forts
courageux et ambitieux mais avec ces
comportements recommandé viennent aussi
des interdictions ainsi elle est fille a
très tôt on va à nous décourager d'être
trop turbulente de prendre trop de place
de parler trop fort de nous mettre en
colère et les garçons vont être
découragés de pleurer quand ils sont
tristes de dire quand ils ont peur de
parler de leurs émotions
pourtant si l'être humain un panel aussi
large aux scieries aussi coloré
d'émotion c'est bien parce que on a
besoin de chacune d'entre elles pour
ressentir interpréter et réagir aux
événements qu'on rencontre et on peut
pas en supprimer ou les interchanger
privé si tôt les enfants d'une partie de
leur émotion c'est créer chez les hommes
un déséquilibre qui vont porter jusqu'à
l'âge adulte
c'est comme ça que nous les femmes
une fois adulte on va avoir du mal à se
mettre en colère quand on se sent
agressé ou déranger je sais pas si vous
avez déjà vu dans la rue ou dans les
transports des femmes qui sont harcelés
ou même au travail
une collègue qui est serré de trop près
par un collègue un peu libye line qui
lui tient l'épaule qui lui parle trop
frais et qui lui fait des blagues
salaces et bien dans ce genre de
situation on a tendance à sourire et
c'est pas parce qu'on aime ça que le
collègue libidineux à ils nous touchent
et qu'il nous fasse des blagues pourries
en fait c'est parce que on est gêné mais
qu'on nous a toujours appris que se
mettre en colère s'étaient pas féminin
et qu'il fallait pas dérangé et pour ne
pas le déranger lui eh ben on se laisse
être dérangé nous alors les hommes eux
ils ont moins de problèmes à se mettre
en colère quand ils se sentent agressés
ils savent se défendre
par contre ils vont pas s'autoriser à
pleurer quand ils sont tristes ils vont
pas s'autoriser à dire quand ils ont
peur et ils vont pas parler de leurs
émotions ni s'ouvrir à celle des autres
lorsque pour eux ça c'est un truc de
femmes en ce moment le mardi
j'accompagne l'école de mon fils à la
piscine et vous savez ce qu'ils se
disent les petits garçons dans les
vestiaires quand ils veulent se moquer
les uns des autres ou qui sont fâchés
ils se traitent de filles comme si
c'était une insulte et je peux vous
garantir que dans le vestiaire des
filles dans lequel je vais parfois aussi
donnant un coup de main eh bien personne
se traite de garçons en fait les enfants
ils font que renvoyé parce que le monde
adulte leur montre que le masculin c'est
positif comporte toit en sommes il faut
avoir des couilles pour réussir mais
fais pas ta gonzesse du court tu lances
comme une fille car ces catégories en
fait qu'on nous attribue elles sont
distinctes avoir opposé mais elles sont
aussi hiérarchisé et le masculin c'est
toujours ce qui va être considéré comme
positif le courage l'ambition ce qui
permet de réussir le féminin ça va
toujours être vus comme des qualités un
peu secondaire de seconde zone
futile en fait on s'intéresse au féminin
que quand il vient en support en soutien
du masculin pour lui permettre
d'effectuer son ascension dans la
société
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que derrière
chaque grand homme il ya une femme qui a
travaillé dans l'ombre alors nous les
femmes on se rend assez vite compte
carnac un mois quand j'étais petit j'ai
vu les contes de fées j'ai dit que ça
n'allait pas me convenir il est où le
conte où la princesse elle va tuer des
dragons alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour essayer de sortir un peu de mon
rôle j'essayais de débarrasser de mes
qualités dites féminines et j'ai
longtemps dit pour revaloriser que j'
étais pas une vraie fille sous-entendu
je suis pas coquette et motive je ne
m'intéresse pas à des choses futiles
mais en fait en faisant cela j'ai jamais
obtenu un rôle égal à celui des garçons
au mieux je suis arrivé au statut de
garçon manqué c'est celle qu'a essayé
d'être un garçon mais elle s'est raté au
bout du compte
alors j'ai abandonné j'ai accepté le
rôle que mme attribué à la société et
j'ai développé mes facultés d'empathie
d'émotivité de sensibilité pour les
hommes c'est plus dur de se rendre
compte qu'ils arnaque
pourtant le prix à payer il est là aussi
c'est le poids permanent de devoir
toujours être confiant de toujours avoir
l'air de savoir en va de jamais pouvoir
s'autoriser à pleurer à dire qu'on a
peur a parlé de ses émotions
mais ce poids la plupart des hommes
l'acceptent parce que ça leur permet
d'avoir une place supérieure à celle des
femmes dans la société une place
valoriser un confort financier et
l'accès à une intégrité physique et à
une dignité que les femmes n'ont pas
toujours
alors vous dit peut-être qu'en même
temps le monde est comme ça qu il faut
se masculiniser pour réussir être
compétitif être le meilleur
être ambitieux je vais vous raconter
autre chose je vous ai déjà dit que
j'étais une femme je suis aussi une
ingénieure en informatique
j'ai effectué ce métier pendant douze
ans j'ai développé des logiciels et
j'adorais ça quand le code se mettait en
place pour faire exactement ce que
j'attendais lui qu'il fasse j'ai
toujours trouvé soit plus simple que la
vie réelle un et quand j'ai commencé à
travailler j'ai évolué dans des équipes
plutôt mixte et au début j'ai pas eu
besoin de changer
j'étais toujours douces empathique et
serviable le matin je la portais des
gâteaux à mes collègues je connaissais
les prénoms de leurs enfants
je m'inquiétais 2 quand il était malade
et quand des nouvelles recrues arrivait
je leur montrais les locaux je leur
montrais leur poste de travail j'étais
toujours disponible pour les aider à
monter en compétences dans leur tâche et
je pense vraiment pas que ça faisait
deux mois une moins bonne ingénieur et
je pense encore moi je suis sûr que ça
faisait deux mois
une bonne personne et une bonne
collègues mais après j'ai voulu prendre
des responsabilités
alors je suis monté d'un cran dans la
hiérarchie et autour de moi il y avait
plus que des hommes
jacky la responsabilité de l'équipe de
qualité du logiciel qu'on a développé le
travail de mon équipe c'est est de
s'assurer que le logiciel faisait
marcher bien qu'il avait pas de bug et
qu'il faisait exactement ce qu'on
attendait de lui qu'il fasse
sauf que ce n'était pas l'objectif de
mon entreprise
l'objectif de mon entreprise c'était de
vendre ce logiciel au plus grand nombre
de clients possible pour le plus cher
possible et qui lui coûte le moins cher
possible alors il investissait beaucoup
sur le commerce le marketing et très peu
sur nous les ingénieurs qui produisions
le logiciel et on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation on est obligé de se battre
chaque chef d'equipe les uns contre les
autres pour avoir des ressources pour
son équipe
alors je précise que quand je parle de
ressources
je parle d'ingénieurs des vrais gens
avec des vrais bras et des vrais jambes
qui vont développer le logiciel et on se
les batailles est comme si c'était à des
chaises des tables ou des ramettes de
papier c'est ce à quoi on était réduit
alors on faisait des réunions où on
était tous autour d'une table et chacun
essayait de parler plus fort que le
voisin pour avoir des ressources pour
son équipe
tout le monde criait c'est un point où
quand je finissais pas réussir à avoir
quelqu'un eh bien il ya des chefs
d'equipe qui est débarqué dans mon
bureau par deux ou trois ils
s'arrêtaient debout devant ma chaise il
se met à me crier dessus pour que je
rende l'ingénieur moi ça me faisait le
même effet que si dark vador venait de
rentrer dans mon vaisseau comme ça
j'avais la bouche sèche le coeur qui
tapait à fond les mains qui tremblaient
et j'avais envie de trouver la table la
plus proche pour cacher dessous ils
attendent qu'ils partent mais je pouvais
pas faire ça parce que j'étais chef
alors j'essaie de m'imposer je me levais
aussi je parlais fort je criais pour
garder mon ingénieur et puis une fois
qu'ils étaient partis
je craquais j'allais pleurer en cachette
à cette époque j'ai fait une dépression
et j'ai dû abandonner mon poste et mon
père a récupéré mon fils de renens parce
que j'allais trop mal et que je
n'arrivais plus à m'en occuper et je me
suis dit que j'avais échoué j'avais
échoué à me débarrasser de ma féminité
demain douceur de mon émotivité j'avais
échoué à me comporter en homme
sauf que quelques années plus tard j'ai
appris que cette entreprise que j'avais
dû quitter eh bien ça ne s'y passait pas
très bien déjà parce que les ingénieurs
qui travaillent avec moi ils partaient
tous soit démissionner soit il partait
en congé maladie parce qu'ils étaient en
dépression et quand j'ai appris ça j'ai
compris plusieurs choses la première
c'est que c'est pas moi qui avait échoué
à me comporter en homme c'est mon
entreprise qui avait échoué à créer un
environnement où on aurait pu tous
collaboré chacun avec nos qualités en
gardant notre sérénité notre dignité et
plus largement c'est la société qui
échoue à permettre à des entreprises qui
collaborent dans le respect de chacun à
prendre de prendre leur place et qui
promeuvent celles qui sont compétitives
et qui encouragent l'agressivité entre
les employés la deuxième chose que j'ai
compris c'est que les ingénieurs qui
travaillent avec moi il était aussi peu
à l'aise que moi dans le conflit il
n'aimait pas la compétition permanente
je pense qu'il n'aimait pas du tout
crier nice faire crier dessus à mon avis
ils avaient peur parfois et souvent
envie de pleurer penser que le masculin
ou en tout cas ce conte les secousses
qu'on considère aujourd'hui comme m
masculin seule est à même de faire du
bon travail d équipe
c'est une erreur alors à titre
individuel je pense que oui
effectivement ça permet de préparer son
ascension dans la société de sortir son
épingle du jeu d'être le meilleur est
devant les autres mais ça permet pas de
collaborer en équipe et de faire du
travail de qualité qui respecte toutes
les personnes qui vont participer
les qualités dites masculines sont
utiles le courage l'ambition l'esprit
d'entreprise oui mais sans leurs
complémentaires l'empathie l'hésitation
la prudence une dose de peur émincer
qualité elles deviennent des défauts
elles peuvent devenir dangereuses elles
peuvent pousser des hommes à être
violent envers eux mêmes et envers les
autres
elles peuvent conduire des entreprises à
mener des politiques managériale
toxiques toxiques pour les employés et
qui provoque des vagues de suicides
elles peuvent mener des entreprises à
mettre en vente par exemple du lait
infantile contaminés et de ne pas le
retirer même si elle le sait en disant
que ça va passer ou d'autres entreprises
à déverser des produits toxiques dans la
mer là où on sait que des gens se
baignent ou pêche des poissons qu'on va
consommer ou des entreprises qui
produisent et vendent des armes sans se
préoccuper voir en se réjouissant de ce
à quoi elles vont servir notre monde
aujourd'hui
il a été construit par et pour des
hommes des hommes à qui on dit depuis
tout petits qui ne faut pas être
empathique qui ne faut pas avoir peur
qu'il ne faut pas à dire quand on est
tristes qu'il faut être toujours le
meilleur
toujours dans la compétition et le monde
dans lequel on vit
il est à l'image de ses hommes il est
concurrentiel impitoyable est sur le
déclin
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce que on
continue la compétition
la loi du plus fort pour voir jusqu'où
ça nous mais non
où est ce qu'on prend un instant pour
essayer de redresser la barre moi ce que
je pense c'est qu'on devrait tous se
mettre en pause quelques temps
et puis chacun retrouvez la totalité de
nos émotions
la partie dont on nous a privé quand on
était petit alors pour nous les femmes
ça va impliquer de retrouver confiance
en nous la confiance de se mettre en
colère quand on se sent agressé ou
dérangé prendre la place qui nous
revient légitimement parler fort trouver
enfin le sens la légitime
et de valoriser nos qualités d'empathie
leur donner une vraie place dans la
société
et puis pour les hommes ça pourrait bien
consister à enfin retirées de leurs
épaules ce poids invisible mais
permanent de devoir toujours être fort
confiant avoir l'air de savoir où on va
et de ne jamais pouvoir s'autoriser à
pleurer pouvoir enfin parler de ses
émotions se montrait sentimentale sans
avoir peur d'être traités de filles et
peut-être qu'une fois qu'on aura fait ce
travail on va se rendre compte qu'on
n'est pas vraiment différent les hommes
et les femmes que ces catégories elles
ont quelque chose d'artificiel et qu'en
fait on est plutôt des êtres humains
et sinon on change c'est possible que
notre regard sur la société y changent
aussi qu'on commence à de se demander
après quoi on a couru tout ce temps
pourquoi on voulait être meilleur que
les autres toujours le premier toujours
dans la réussite et nos priorités vont
sûrement changer on va avoir envie de se
tourner vers nos proches prendre soin de
ceux qui en ont besoin
s'intéresser à l'humanité à la planète
sur laquelle on vit et puis moi ce que
je pense c'est que ce travail pour nous
il va être difficile à faire parce que
on a des dizaines d'années de
construction à défaire derrière nous
mais on peut l'éviter aux générations
qui viennent en élevant nos enfants
comme des enfants des humains pas comme
des garçons et des filles en arrêtant de
considérer le masculin comme une insulte
et le féminin comme le bascule un comme
un compliment et le féminin comme une
insulte en laissant nos petites filles
et turbulente se mettre en colère en les
laissant prendre la place qui leur
revient et en laissant nos gars ont
pleuré montrer leur sensibilité dire
quand ils ont peur parler de leurs
émotions et moi ce que j'espère c'est
que ces enfants ils vont trouver
beaucoup plus tôt que nous leur
équilibre
ils vont devenir des adultes équilibrée
et ce que j'espère c'est que la somme
plus tarder
tous ces adultes qui auront trouvé leur
équilibre va former à son tour une
société empathique collaborative et qui
livrés merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]